[Music]
a seismic shift in Italy's political
landscape the established center left
Democratic Party and Italy's
anti-establishment 5 star movement have
agreed to put aside their differences
and join forces to form a government the
outgoing Prime Minister political
independent Giuseppe Conte who resigned
last week returns to the top job there
on governo berry it will be government
to the good of the citizens a government
which will help modernize the country
and make our nation more competitive
internationally but also more just more
supportive and more inclusive the
surprised partnership puts an end to the
first post-war populist government in
Western Europe Italian politics imploded
earlier this month when Deputy Prime
Minister Matteo salvini withdrew his
league party from its turbulent alliance
with the five star movement the
right-wing firebrand had hoped to
exploit his party's popularity to
trigger snap elections and become prime
minister if successful it could have led
to the creation of a fully far-right
government but the plan spectacularly
backfired salvini is furious accusing
Brussels Berlin and Paris of potting
against him happy
we've been direct and honest with the
president to whom we've expressed
bewilderment the bewilderment not just
of our party but of millions of Italians
looking on at this ridiculous political
show a game of power has been going on
for days between the Democratic Party
and the five star movement
Salvy knees drawn fierce criticism and
won support for his crackdown on boats
trying to bring stranded migrants to
Italy putting relations with other EU
members under strain he described
African refugees as an army of benefit
thieves and criminals once the most
influential man in government salvini is
now the most powerful man in opposition
and the league still remains the
country's most popular party the new
coalition is united against a common
enemy it will need to hold firm to keep
salvini at bay
Nev Parker al Jazeera